but I'm happier now than I have ever  been so sure I am even though it's  shitty and every day I have to fortify  myself to walk out the door  I'm mentally and physically I have to  make sure I look perfect all around and  I have to make sure that my mental state  is one that I don't have to  feel like I have to blow up at everybody  that says something to me because just  walking down over here I must have got  every remark in the book  every remark everyone people can tell  you're trans and they'll well they like  are you a girl or  ooh or their cat call or or it'd be even  worse you know you won't fear you won't  see a  what do you call a CIS female dressed  like you are in Skid Row  yes yes you do but I have a look that's  a little bit more